[Music]
alex thinks we can afford tuition and we
can't we need to tell her the truth
you always tell the truth that's what we
always say yeah
i think we should do it i'm not gonna do
it me neither we gotta lie
about everything cause that's what
parents do
will ferrell and amy poehler's
characters got desperate trying to pay
for college in their 2017 movie the
house
and in reality many american families do
struggle to foot the bill student loan
debt stands at more than 1.6 trillion
dollars that's an
average of more than 37 thousand dollars
per
student a new book seeks to demystify
the college financial process
it's called the price you pay for
college an entirely new roadmap for the
biggest financial decision your family
will ever
make author ron lieber is the your money
columnist for the new york times and he
joins us now
ron i'm so glad you're here i want to
get into the cost of college but i want
to start with a threshold question that
i think a lot of people will ask
themselves
is college worth it if you're on the
fence about whether you or your child
should apply what do you tell them
well you tell them that the lifetime
income benefit that comes from going to
college is worth roughly a million
dollars on
average over your life so if it is money
and um
you know rising through the the social
class ranks that matters to you or
staying where you are
you probably do want to go to college
because it's much harder to earn a
decent living
if you don't good answer an extra
million dollars sounds pretty nice now
the cost of college on average has
doubled in the past 20 years are we
getting twice as much education
no look here's the issue the
the the undergraduate education as it's
delivered
hasn't really changed all that much but
it's become more expensive for the
schools
the state schools get less of subsidies
from from the state legislatures and so
they have to raise tuition
the private schools have expensive
people professors administrators
the very people we want on campus to
help our kids get to and through
so there's a reason for the prices going
up but i'm not sure that we're getting
double the value that we did a
generation ago
that's troubling well there's the cost
on the website of any university or
college and then there's a so-called
true
cost what's the difference and is it
really negotiable can you get it down to
a number you can afford
sure the list prices the so-called cost
of attendance that you find
on a college's website is one thing and
that might be up to 80
000 for some private universities that's
per year now
but the net price is something different
right you may get need-based financial
aid
or there may be these unpublished merit
eight discounts that have nothing to do
with how much money you have but may
have
everything to do with who you are how
your kids did in school and how much
that school
may want to and may want to in effect
buy your kid
with a 10 or a 20 or a 30 000 annual
coupon
one of the more interesting moments in
the book is when you talk about having
conversations with your kids at about
eighth grade
where you point out that good grades are
not only good because you're going to
learn more it'll prepare you for your
future
but you're literally going to get
dollars if you do better potentially
when colleges look at your transcript
walk us through that conversation how do
you make that clear to kids because when
you're in eighth grade you're like look
i mow the lawn i make 15 bucks you don't
know what 30
000 in debt really feels like
so this is the challenge here right and
there are no good choices in this
aspect of parenting because the system
of paying for college is so
complicated if we don't tell our kids
about these unpublished discounts
they're probably going to find out about
them anyway whether through the internet
or through older siblings and so i
feel like it's our job to let them know
gently
how exactly the system works we should
let them know that we trust them
that we believe in them and that they
can handle the truth
you dedicate the book to your daughter
violet who you write is worth every
penny as every parent feels about their
children
isn't that why these colleges and
universities kind of have us in a bad
negotiating position
they know we'll do anything we can
within reason or even beyond reason
to support our kids future and therefore
they can charge anything they want how
do you take emotion out of this or can
you
it's almost impossible part of what i'm
trying to do with my readers is make
them more emotionally honest with
themselves
the schools know very well that this is
a head trip for us right we have
fear that they're going to go tumbling
down the social class ladder if we make
the wrong choice
we have guilt that we haven't saved
enough or earned enough to pay for this
out of pocket
and there's some snobbery and elitism
around you know which schools are best
and
how people are going to look at their
kids and our kids when we graduate
right so the schools know this good and
well we have to be honest with ourselves
about confronting these feelings and
making sure those feelings
do not lead us to make decisions and
take on debt that we may regret
later on brian you caught our attention
at the top an extra million dollars
people should hear on average lifetime
earning difference if you go to college
your book is an important way to help
people understand how they can pay that
upfront cost
to get that big benefit down the line
ron lieber thank you very much